let's do
this
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to
a live version of your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all welcome to uh riffin
with griffin we're doing it live because
i just
got back from florida and i did not have
time to do anything so i'm doing it all
live in full effect here for you right
here right now
that's how we gonna do it so thanks for
uh being here and that's how we're gonna
do it so but uh before we uh get going
with that
let me go here
um
uh where is it i mean when you do it
live by yourself you know today's
episode is uh brought to you by
doordash
doordash connects you with everything
you want whenever and however you want
it get 25
percent off and zero delivery fees on
your first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and enter
code griffin
do that
all right guys uh thanks for being here
um like i say i just got back from
florida uh so right now what you're
looking at right now is um
somebody a guy named christopher
from pittsburgh pennsylvania not
pittsburgh but from pennsylvania he sent
this beautiful picture i think this i
don't this is some place on a hike he
goes on so this is like a beautiful
background of today
and that's how we're doing that uh so
this is this is this background today um
let's see
i was in florida so i was going to miami
i was in tampa last week and so i was
going to the miami improv this week and
my rachel my fiancee she has her uncle
lives her uncle lives in uh miami and
her grandmother lives in miami who we've
been doing a zoom call with every sunday
well you know i haven't been on it as
much as before but anyways so i said to
her you want to go with me and she's
like yeah i'll go with you and so we go
she comes with me to uh
you know florida we go to florida
so
uh you know so we saw she saw her
grandma and then we met up with her
cousins it was her one of her cousins
birthdays so they came to the show we
all went to dinner
uh you know it was cool and you know so
it was like a little family outing with
rachel and her and her family and then
we went to dinner the last night we went
to dinner with her uncle
and we saw her other cousin you know
so it's kind of cool to see the family
and her uncle lives in this like really
swanky part of miami beach
in this like high rise it overlooks like
the the wealthiest per capita wealthiest
neighborhood in all of the united states
is this like private island in miami and
his place overlooks that
it was really nice really beautiful um
so you know we did that and it was fun i
actually enjoyed having rachel on the
road with me uh just because like you
know you're in the hotel even though i'm
still doing my stream and by the way
make sure you check me out uh i'm still
doing that
uh daily
you know so make sure you check me out
on eric griffin gaming i will be gaming
after this podcast so check me out on
eric griffin gaming
um yeah so i was i was gaming and she
was there you know so she was looking at
paris hilton on peacock
and i was you know playing warzone on my
computer on my xbox little setup that i
have and it was just kind of cool i kind
of like proximity i don't know what your
love languages are but one of the things
i do enjoy is proximity like i don't
necessarily have to be interacting and
doing stuff but i like that that the
feel of someone you love or care about
is like near you
i sort of like that so
that's uh you know what that situation
was about so that so that was fun and
then like we went to a nice italian
restaurant but you know it was cool and
and then like you know the miami crowds
it was fine you know i just you know
just to really to talk about like how
different it is
all over the united states it's all the
united states and actually the world
like it's so different every place with
like their different covitt restrictions
and i'm not going to go into a big covet
thing guys you know because
thanksgiving's coming up right now and i
feel like if when you're at thanksgiving
and people start talking about covenant
in the vaccine i'm gonna be like oh can
we talk about religion you know what i
mean like
that would be better than that so i'm
not gonna go away but it's just
as someone that travels it is amazing
how like three weeks ago i'm going to
canada and i have to
get a cova test and be vaccinated and i
have to get two covet tests there and
back and then it's like the mask
restrictions are everywhere and then you
go to florida and it's just willy-nilly
man they don't you know
no masks
you know it just says like if you're
vaccinated you know
it's your choice it was very much more
open and it was a whole different
attitude about it so it's just like kind
of like mind-boggling to like when you
travel as much as i do to try to figure
out
where you're going and like you know
like okay what is it going to be the in
this particular place is it going to be
more strict in the last place and so to
me it's all bananas but it would be like
airport security being different
everywhere
like you know it don't make any sense
like if this thing is affecting everyone
why aren't we all doing the same stuff
so you know it's hard to wrap your brain
around that sometimes but you know it is
what it is
i got it done
um and the shows were great shows were
fun i wish i wish it was packed but i
mean i think coming into the holiday
weekend you know
i think you know i don't know i don't
know why people come see me or don't see
me or you know sometimes when i do
really well i go oh yeah these people
love me and then other times i'm like i
don't think anybody likes me at all you
know that's just like how you get in
your head as a performer but thanks to
all the people that came out to the
miami improv i appreciate you guys that
was great and uh you know thanks for all
the you know again the king and the
sting fans that have been coming out
appreciate you guys and you hardcore
silent roofing with griffin guys thank
you guys for coming out too so i i
appreciate that and you know it was just
i had a i had a good time you know i saw
one of my childhood friends
man we've known each other since we were
almost kids i think our parents my mom
and her mom went to like high school
together or something i believe so
but it's just weird to see like how
we've like grown you know
so shout out to anya um
and her mom came to the show too so
marilyn shout out to you too and i know
they don't listen to my podcast but it
is what it is
and then rachel came to my show with her
cousins and so then i i have a lot of
material about rachel she loves when i
do that material like it's funny because
even if it's like say disparaging or
negative or you know male verse female
stuff she still loves it because she
goes oh that was all about me
so i can i could kind of appreciate that
sort of like innocence
uh you know about that so that was cool
so yeah so then that that was a good
show and um
you know and i and i i was trying to
sell my dvds
yeah i still have dvds if you go to my
website you can buy my my special the
ugly truth
you know when i got these dvds
i thought i was getting a deal i was
like oh this is going to be great and i
got them right when nobody uses dvds
anymore like i got them right at that
time and so now i have all these dvds
and you know i actually got to send a
few out that was purchased on my on my
website so
and then i got the new shirts you know
uh i don't know if you guys
i got new merch
so make sure you guys go check that out
let me go let me go to this
i'm i'm over here by myself today
but i got i got new merch can you go to
the store off the website i don't know i
don't know if you can
you know they have they have these shops
oh yeah you can't do it off of uh
you can't do it off the website but yeah
i got new merch made from this picture
right here i'll still show it to you
so i got my my
i'm a woo woo boy
riffing with griffin shirts
off this great image made by reuben
t800 reuben at instagram he's a
fantastic artist so i made some merch if
you go to my instagram it's free
shipping so if you want to check that
out right there make sure you check that
out
uh let's go back to desk and once again
shout out to chris in pennsylvania for
this great background for today's show
so yeah
um
all right let's just get into it you
know what am i gonna talk about you know
what i gotta talk about i mean i'm just
this kind of guy i mean i gotta talk
about this this thing
you know
um i gotta i you know i gotta give my
thoughts on it it is what it is you know
what i'm saying it is what it is oh
he's looking at me it is what it is but
let's talk about this kyle
rittenhouse
case
all right
um
first of all
let me just say this
you can have different opinions
than someone else or someone has a
different opinion than you you don't got
to attack them personally
and and you guys that listen to my
podcast a lot
you know i like to take a common sense
nuanced approach
i got some nuance merch coming too by
the way guys we're gonna have some
nuance to merch
i like to take a common sense nuance
approach
to this
subject
so i got a lot to say
and i know you all got a lot to say and
i'm doing it live so i'm checking myself
live you know we're doing this live
there's the ch i see you chat right
there thanks for being in here
but let me just say this i'm gonna make
this simple
two things can be true
first i wanna say this about the kyle
ryden house case all right
this dude
took a lethal weapon into a situation
and some lethal [ __ ] happened
to me
he should be accountable for that
and
i think
that he
was was used in self-defense i think
both things can be true
i think both things can be true
you see
i don't understand so this is a grand a
bigger issue than what is being made of
it in the you know with the
the house being politicized but to me
this is more about the laws this is more
about
not in even necessarily gun control but
like you know in the same way that you
have to have insurance to drive a car
you have to have a license to have a car
you can't be 16 you 16 you have a
learner's permit by 18 you have you know
you you have your license uh but like
you know you can't rent a car until
you're 25 unless you spend a bunch of
money because there's certain
restrictions that you have in society
about these kinds of things i think
that's the bigger issue
you know what i mean i think that's the
bigger issue here other than this making
this like some kind of racial issue
which is like that's a part of it but
it's not the main part of it and you
know and i think people don't understand
like the court in the court of law it is
all about facts it's all about evidence
and facts what can you prove
and what can you disprove or what you
know it's all about the evidence okay
but let me say this again
this young kid
took a ar-15 gun a lethal weapon into a
situation and some lethal [ __ ] happen
so i think he should be accountable for
that
should it be first-degree murder no i
don't think so because i do also believe
he used it in self-defense but what i'm
saying is he chose that weapon
he chose that weapon he picked this
weapon up was like i'm gonna go do this
thing i don't think he knew what he was
doing i don't think he wanted to smoke
you know there's a whole thing about
like don't point a gun unless you
willing to use it once you pick that up
and you take it out you're saying i'm
willing to use this weapon
i you know it's like you should be
accountable for that
like let's look at the charges
you know you got you got to look at the
charges because this is important and
i'm saying this is where the issue
really is in my opinion
you know um
first degree intentional homicide do i
think he was
do i think it was that no
attempted first degree intentional
homicide
that gets kind of iffy but first degree
i don't know
first degree reckless homicide like is
there a second degree is there a third
degree
is there first degree reckless endanger
endangering safety like
like
is there a second and third degree to
this like these are the ones they went
for and and maybe with the evidence it
doesn't fall under these things but i
think it should fall under some of this
something it should fall under like i
say guys let me say this again so you
get me again
i think that he was he did use
self-defense
his life was in danger you know because
it was a some dangerous [ __ ] going on
like people act like it was some sort of
peaceful
peaceful protest going on no no this
wasn't a peaceful protest there was some
violent stuff going on and this kid
put himself in a situation that he
couldn't handle with a gun he obviously
couldn't really handle uh you know he
didn't want that smoke and this terrible
thing happened so so all the people that
are saying like you should have a right
to defend yourself i go yeah
i feel what you're saying but what i'm
saying is this is a grander issue it's
like why are we still using lethal force
like what's up with the gun companies
like why aren't we using why are we
still selling lethal force why is why is
it still that
why is for the last 200 years
that's the only weapon we can make is
shooting little pieces of metal at each
other like there's no like we're in 2021
billionaires are going into space and we
don't got phaser guns yet we don't got
non-lethal weapons yet we don't have
like
the fact that that's the only option
is to me part of the problem you see
what i'm saying it's a grander issue
other than that what's happening right
now like i say like i think people do
have a right to defend themselves i
think people have a right to defend
their property i think you know what i
mean i just don't think this particular
kid handled this in the right way you
know he drove four hours to go do this
and then he again he had a lethal gun
and once you pick it up you're saying to
yourself even if you don't realize
you're saying this i might have to use
this
and that means i might hurt or kill
someone
and i think that if you're making that
choice i think you should be accountable
for that
you know
you know this he could have he could
have got a baseball bat
okay he could have picked up anything
else he could have said let's let's do
this with with crowbars let's do this
like you know with fists he was he could
have defended himself in many different
ways but he chose a gun
you know
right to bear arms or not there is a
responsibility you have like you have a
right to drive a car but you can't just
run somebody over
you know you can't you have to follow
the traffic laws
so i just feel like
i want to re reiterate this again
i think that these charges that he was i
think that these charges are some of
them are too stiff and i think they
should have been going for some other
charges but i think there was some sort
of political pressure or something like
that was what um you know was going on
but i just feel like um
i feel like this is an issue that should
be talked about with legislation you
know because by the way so then i've
seen a lot of like you know there's like
the woke left sort of types that are
making it all about race it's all about
race and all that stuff and
and i feel like there's an element to
that
but like let's just talk about the facts
of this case and what was happening in
this situation i you know i think that
the jury
i think the judge was a little biased
and but i think the jury made the
correct choice i think that they with
the evidence was that was presented they
were like okay so you're like i don't
see
first degree of these things that
they're going for that he did these
things like that maybe it was third
degree
uh
third degree reckless homicide if that's
even a thing maybe it was third degree
reckless endangerment of safety because
i think that he should again he should
be accountable because he picked up a
lethal weapon and lethal [ __ ] happened
and so he should have something he
should be accountable for that
and it can also be true
that he was acting in self-defense but
he chose the
he chose how he was gonna use his
self-defense so you know i'm looking on
the instagram and i'm seeing all these
people and they're talking about you
know well now everybody's going to be
using self-defense as an excuse
well you know what though
i feel like see i'm not for looting and
rioting and [ __ ]
i'm not one of these people that thinks
that's the way to get things done there
are people out there that think that's
the way to do it well what i'm saying is
if you're making that choice you know
what
you're also going to get some some heat
for that too because there's people out
there who own businesses that are not on
that side and they just are like yo why
are you looting my place and they have
the right to defend themselves too so
maybe that's going to be a deterrent
you know maybe that's going to be a
deterrent like you know it's a terrible
thing that happened when when terrible
things happen you have to look back and
go what did we do right or wrong in this
situation and i don't think people
should have been out there it was a
violent situation and it just it it
it blew up into something terrible a
tragedy where two people are dead
another person's injured and this guy
and this kid is a killer okay regardless
of whatever you say that's gonna be on
his soul forever and you saw the way he
just was reacting in court he wasn't
ready for that smoke he didn't want that
smoke man he didn't want that
you know and and he should have known
that when he picked up that gun now let
me talk about something else when i
because this is what i'm saying about
like where i feel like this is an issue
that has to do with the laws
i think it has to do with like the
legislation of how we do things because
i know this isn't the same thing but i
just want to give you an example of
something where
the laws are really strange
uh like so here's an example i want to
talk about what i was looking up was
dog biting like if your dog bites a
thief
can that thief sue
and in some cases they can and and if
you look at this right here it's the
it's the it's the so-called one-bite
rule but it applies to all domestic
animals and all types of injuries under
the old common law burglars could be
compensated because the policy of law
was dead set against having such animals
okay so they so they they made these
laws
and they had it where it was this kind
of thing and it's rare cases where a
criminal a thief cannot sue but it can't
happen if it says like where's this
there's a great line here um
uh
okay a juror might say that the burglar
wins if the dog was known to be a killer
of people all right so check that out if
a burglar gets bitten by a dog a jury
might say that that burglar wins if the
dog was known to be a killer of people
but the jury might also say that the
incident was 95 the fault of the burglar
which is true you know so it's like
they're saying that if it's a dog that
has previously been known to bite people
right
so what i'm saying is they thought about
this so they said like okay well here's
this situation so there's rare cases
where a thief could be like yo your dog
bit me i know i'm robbing you but your
dog bit me what i'm saying is like
there's no thought like that about a gun
you know like it's like
this gun is known to kill people
you know what i mean like it's known to
have lethal implications
to me it's like something it's something
similar there in like the thought
process
again i'm not saying it's the same thing
i'm just pointing out how
how there are times when they delve deep
into these laws
and
you know to make it work you know what i
mean
so it's like it's a it's a strange thing
so you know this goes back to like you
know what kind of gun control we're
gonna have and and all this kind of
stuff and you know i just feel like to
me it's like let people have guns if you
want to have guns have guns but maybe
you should have to have a license to
have a gun you know and so maybe you
know it's like if you're if you're if
you're an expert in jiu jitsu
and like if like if written if kyle
rittenhouse was an expert in jiu jitsu
okay
and these guys came at him in a
situation
he could have killed all three of them
with jiu jitsu
you know what i mean
what if he was a black belt in jiu jitsu
when he was just out there like
what you you looting fool pal and he
just broke necks
would it be self-defense
would it be self-defense
i think it would be harder to prove
self-defense if he was a trained killer
because you know when you're a trained
killer you can't get into just regular
fights like you can't get into a regular
fight if you're a trained killer
you it has to be
completely instigated by the other
person you have to have witnesses or
your ass is going to go to jail
but a gun a gun is just fine
no training
no license to have it
nothing you know it's just i feel like
there's something wrong there you know
i think there's something wrong there so
i just feel like
this is a greater issue and i don't like
how it's being politicized in a way that
it's making it some kind of racial black
and white issue again it's not that both
sides you know you know who's laughing
you know who's laughing at at the awoke
left and the conservative right you know
who's laughing at us the gun companies
the gun companies are laughing at us
because we're over here fighting with
each other about this and they're just
like yeah let's just make another
you know a you know an assault rifle and
put it out into the streets go hey yeah
you can have this look what we're doing
and i think that we need to take a step
back and be like yo how can we manage
society better you know how can we like
do this it's like again and i'm not
saying take guns out of people's hands
i'm not saying that at all i mean i
believe in the right for you to have
firearms but it's like damn i don't
believe in the right that everybody
should be able to use it
you know like if you're gonna have it
get some training
like again this kid didn't want to smoke
man he didn't want it
he was out there like oh [ __ ] this is
real he was probably i mean i fee i
actually feel for this kid because he
had to he killed two people man he
killed and i that ain't easy
that's not easy
even if i had a gun in my hand and
someone was coming at me i don't know if
i would have it in me
to kill someone i just that's how i'm
thinking about like you all can talk all
the smack you want but that's a lot
that's a lot to put on a 17 18 year old
now listen he put himself in that
situation he put himself in it
you know he he drove four hours
he knew the job was dangerous when he
took it but i don't think he really knew
how dangerous it was and now we're in
this situation so
i don't know guys
i don't know you know
and again i'm looking at the chat right
now and i'm seeing some of the things
you guys are saying you know it's like
there's a i mean again i don't i'm not
saying take guns away but is it is it a
problem to
make sure that
whoever has a gun is
of right mind uh you know that they
you know that they that they're trained
that they're licensed you know it's like
you know what you know like you know
like when you go get your driver's
license you got to sit in the car
with the dude from the dmv you know what
i mean and he got you got to drive
around and prove
we should do that with guns man this
should be like a somebody from the nra
you know you got to go down to their gun
range you know and you got to be like
they got to be like okay here we go and
you know and you got to like shoot the
gun clean this show that you can like
make choices it should be like that men
in black audition remember in the first
men in black when will smith was out
there and like you know the little
pop-ups come up that's what should
happen like pop-ups should come up you
know and so then like you gotta you know
if you shoot at these pop-ups you're
like ah you know you killed you know you
you know you you know if it's a white
guy you gotta have like just some black
people come up on the pop-ups and see
what happens and you're like okay that
guy was a criminal but that was a school
teacher you shot you know what i'm
saying and then
and then and then we could be like all
right and then you know you go like you
know how you you know you know how you
feel your driver's test it could be it
should be like you know you failed your
gun test
i you failed it so you can't have a gun
what's wrong with that like what's wrong
with
making sure that the person and even
even if you do that you still gonna have
to deal with people who
they just
they just crazy they just made a bad
choice in their life you know there's
plenty of times when you see these
shootings
the dude got the guns legally
he's trained
and he still decided that i want to kill
people you're going to have those people
all right but what's wrong with like
like
should this kid have an ar-15 in his
hand ever
i mean can we just talk about it like
that
and once again let me say this i'ma keep
saying this because you know people
misconstrued your words
i feel like he took a lethal weapon into
a situation and lethal [ __ ] happened he
should be accountable for that and i
also think he was he was
using self-defense
i i think that if i was on that jury i
would have found him innocent too of
those charges that they were charging
him of these first degree charges
you hear what i'm saying
because when you if you like look at the
laws there are so many degrees and so
many different types of thing you know
we watch too much law and order and we
think we know the law but it's really
intense all the different charges you
could be charged with i think they
overshot with this kid i think they
overshot and they did it because of
social pressure and now they're now
they're biting now they're facing the
consequences of that i think that the
prosecution you know like right now the
kid got off
but what if he would have got third
degree reckless endangerment and got
three years probation or something you
get what i'm saying people still would
have complained people still would have
complained they still would have been
like oh that's not enough
but nothing like he got no like nothing
i don't agree with him getting nothing
and i still agree that he was using self
defense i think both things can be true
you know what i'm saying
you know like just because something's
legal don't mean like you know say just
because something's legal don't mean
that you should do it
you know what i'm saying like that's not
that's not enough
you know just because something's legal
don't mean you should do it man slavery
was legal at a certain time that don't
mean it was that don't mean it was right
it don't mean it was right like come on
man there's still there's still laws on
the books that that's what they have to
have amendments
because
you know
we take people take advantage of the law
man it's just like taxes man you know
it's like like trump like trump was like
you know one thing i liked about trump
when he was talking about like that he
was like yeah i didn't i don't want to
pay taxes
trump was straight up yeah so i you know
i use the loopholes that are in the law
that [ __ ] was legal
he legally didn't pay taxes
you know what i mean
so
yeah this kid legally used the gun
but that don't mean it was right
that'll mean it was right
okay
and i'm just trying to have a common
sense sensible discussion about this
without it turning into like black lives
matter or like white people feeling like
they're like they're they're being
criminalized just for being white we
need to take the discussion away from
that and we need to talk about
you know
what's going on with the judicial system
like what's like that's where the the
issue to me is what happened here again
let's look at this again man
i'm over here by myself so i gotta like
let's look at this again look at what
the charges he was charged with
first degree intentional homicide
man should that be on there
like why were they going for that
you know what i'm saying like really
look at that
why were they going for first degree
intentional homicide
like that's not what the kid like i
don't believe the kid went there i think
the kid was trying to be a cowboy i
think he was like um i think he was a
white dude that was like why is all our
[ __ ] getting looted why can't we defend
ourselves i didn't kill this guy i'm you
know i'm not a cop that did that
we i want to defend my people i want to
defend my neighborhood and i think he
was just like you know he got caught up
in all that [ __ ] and he went out there
and then
and then uh got it got out of hand cause
he couldn't handle it right that's not
first degree intentional homicide why
are they going for that man
and then they went for attempted first
degree intentional homicide like those
first two should not be on there okay
like those two should now be on there
like the prosecution [ __ ] up man those
two should not be on there now when you
come down to the these bottom three i
don't think the first should be in them
i don't think the first should be in
them first degree reckless homicide
first degree reckless endangerment of
safety and first to get reckless
endangerment to safety you know um
reckless and dangerous why is it that
twice
i just noticed that anyway then it's
just the the first one the first and
second one you know so uh not the bottom
one i don't know why they have it there
twice um
you know you know it's like
again like you know like don't get
caught up in
all the don't get caught up in the race
issue man
like we do have a race problem but we're
not going to be able to solve that
problem by just continuously talking
about race
we're not going to solve that problem by
making race the main issue when this has
to do with like you know
like i said it has to do with the laws
and it has to do with like like i think
this i think the prosecution completely
messed up in this situation man
and i think that's why that's why they
got him off i think they saw these
charges and they were like they knew the
law
can they prove first-degree intentional
homicide do you know what you have to do
to prove
that you intended to murder someone like
that's really hard to prove man and it
should be hard to prove because then you
you can't just be throwing people in
jail anyways
i don't want to go on and on about about
that but i just want to make myself
clear
you know um
let me say it again because i want to
keep saying it this kid took
a lethal weapon
he picked up a
he picked up a weapon
that
has lethal consequences
knowingly
and he went out
once you make that choice i'm using this
it means
you know
subconsciously or
consciously you might kill someone
like
what if he had a super soaker
full of acid
okay
if he had a super soaker full of acid
and he went out there would it be
different
i think it'd be a lot different i think
the first degree reckless endangerment
if he would like burn somebody's eyes
out with that thing if he was like
knowingly doing that
i think this kid would be he he might be
serving some time
but for some reason a gun we have a
different thought process about it
it's to me it's crazy to me
like think of all the weapons he could
have chose
he could have he could have taken a
baseball bat with with with nails on the
end you know he could have taken a
chainsaw he could have taken uh
like think of all the weapons he could
have taken that he would have jail time
but a gun
we're over here like oh yeah well you
have a right to do that
it's weird man
you know it's weird so
again guys don't you know i don't i
think that this discussion is more
nuanced than we're giving it it's more
gray area than we're giving it you know
it's like again like
i can have some compassion for both
sides man again i feel for this kid who
who like even if he's like even if it
turns out he's a member of the clan
secretly and this is what his plan was
all along well then if that was his plan
all along the the prosecution really did
a shitty job is what i'm saying you know
they didn't find no evidence you know
what i mean
all i'm saying is like a kid he murdered
two people man
like he's gonna have to live with that i
don't care what he feels about defense
and all that stuff he gotta live with
that and that's sad
and of course i feel even more horrible
for the families of these people that
like they're you know they're dead
you know whatever they were doing out
there they were doing out there but it
was dead and it all stemmed from you
know again you know you talk about let's
go back the police brutality and the
response to that
the police brutality was bad the
response to the police brutality was bad
the response to the response to the
police brutality was bad
it was bad all the way around man
you know the cops did some bad [ __ ] the
people responding to what the cops did
they started doing some bad stuff the
people responding to the people
responding to the cops they did some bad
stuff they picked up guns and they went
out and shot people
in defense
still people are dead
so
that's how i feel about it
um
i know it's a hot button issue
i encourage all of you to have some
compassion for for for all for both
sides
i really do i encourage you
to think about
why this happened
because that's the gonna be the thing
that's gonna solve the issue
why
this happened
and it's so much more nuanced
and
gray area than the s does the the
nonsense that i see on instagram
it is so much more than that
it's more than like you know the white
people who are out there like you have a
right second amendment right you to
defend yourself
like the people that have that stance
i'm like come on man it's more than that
and then the other people who are like
america is racist and the judicial
system is against black people and and
look this kid went out and did this it's
like the people that are talking like
that too chill you need to chill on that
too we need to like come together and
discuss it in a way that we can actually
make some real change
i'm doing this [ __ ] live this is live in
full effect i'm not scripted i'm not
you know what i mean i'm not cutting
anything out this is me talking to y'all
straight from the heart right here you
know and i feel sad
i do i feel sad sad for the state of
things because
we just need some intelligent
compassionate discussion
so we can
really make some
improvements so for all you people that
hate this kid have some compassion for
him because he's gonna have to live with
that
and
all you people out there who are just
you know thinking
whatever you're thinking about
on that's on the other side
you know come on
there's more to this than that you know
there's more to life than just race
there's more to life you know what i
mean
you know we want to all get along and
and and
thrive in this beautiful system that was
created you can say what you want but
this capitalist system this this country
of freedoms
man it's a beautiful thing but it gets
challenged and when it gets challenged
like this we have to stand together and
find a way to come through the other
side without just this fighting and and
you know this this [ __ ] this divide
that we have
you know what i mean
let's
yes i do read the comments
people are asking me do you read the
comments there's a lot of comments
coming man i can't
i can't read all the comments man so
you know it is it is what it is that's
what i'm saying all right
so
this this isn't pre-recorded anonymous i
am
reading your comments in full time
all right so enough with that
let's get to something lighter to finish
the podcast off
okay uh i want to talk about you know i
like to talk about the shows and stuff
that i watch so
i was watching this show on netflix and
it's called
arcane
league of legends
it's an animated show
it's an animated show and it's on
netflix uh let me look up the imdb of it
and i gotta tell you man this sucker i i
binge watched this
so fast
it was so good man
uh um i i really i'm gonna tell you all
the things let me just look it up first
arcane league of legends there we go
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go arcane league of legends
arcane league of legends everybody
listening later i know how you you're
probably like oh man what are you doing
but it is what it is yeah there's a lot
of oh wow a lot of great people in this
um yeah this is this this was a really
great show man
it was um like i said it's an animated
show
it's it's about
i don't know some like it's based off a
video game i i would imag i think so i
think it's based off a video game
um but
it's some weird world you know where
like science and magic sort of coexist
or magic
did exist at a particular time but it
did some you know and there's like
different types of races that's you know
little fur guys that live 300 years and
you know there's like you know of course
there's like a class system you know you
got the the rich people that live on the
top and then you have the underground
people who are like thieves and you know
they have to like you know scrounge and
they have to fight for everything that
they got and they're fighting against
the people up top but it's just
beautifully drawn like the animation is
really rich and beautiful like if you
can see it right there on the screen if
you're looking on youtube like that's
how the animation looked uh but this but
the acting was great like the voice
acting was so good
and the story was good
and usually these things are not very
good like i see somebody in the chat
saying that usually video game adaptions
to film they suck
but this was this wasn't sucky at all
this i mean it would like it was so good
i mean i don't want to spoil anything
but it just has like like these
shakespearean themes of like
you know father and daughter and and
like you know sisters who like are
sisters who become enemies but they're
still sisters and then
you know the the this villain who like
he's of like it's one of those villains
that you can kind of like empathize with
because you know he's doing it for his
people
uh
you know what i mean and there's like
there's like science to it's like magic
and science combined
uh you know you know and it's like
uh you know
like people that have these like huge
ambitions but then those ambitions like
it's like you know they turned they they
used dynamite to make fireworks and it
was supposed to be something for
entertainment and then of course
somebody takes that and turns it into a
weapon and now we have an atomic bomb
you know what i mean so that's the same
kind of thing that's happening in this
you know the guy comes up with this you
know this tech uh this sort of magic
mixed tech and he's trying to use it to
make the world a better place but then
people want to weaponize it and you know
it's in the show's kind of sexy and and
you know what it's very ethnic and you
don't even think about that because the
the story is so good and and the drawing
and everything is so pleasant like i i
binged through this so fast because i
really enjoyed it so make sure you check
out arcane
league of legends i get i give it a i
give it a thumbs up man no i'm not nope
no we don't do that right i'm giving it
five woo-woo's
[Music]
you right that's right somebody's saying
in the chat to music yeah the music was
good too like the cinematography of the
the cinematography was great the music
was great
um
yeah this was like a really great show
man you know let me i don't want to show
too much of this preview that they're
showing right now because
like you get dinged on netflix for for
it but just take a quick just i'm gonna
take a quick peek at like
like the little trailer you know what i
mean
like like that's how it looked you know
what i mean and it just
it was really fantastic like i say the
cinematography
was great the drawing was great and it
was like and it was well done in terms
of like it wasn't like
crass or
you know like the the the female form
the females were sexy but it wasn't like
overdone like anime where it's like you
know
big ass titties and whatever you know
for for no
reason you know you felt for these
characters like i i really felt for them
but anyways
um
yeah
i don't know what else to say man i'm
still like reeling from this discussion
i had about the the the you know
the written house [ __ ] but you know what
i mean i hope you guys can appreciate
my point of view
and you know you take from this what you
will
to like you know really give it some
thought man you know what i mean give it
some thought
don't don't just make it
you know try to have some compassion for
the other side first and then make your
your opinion like having an off
informed opinion
you know what i mean and don't be mad at
the other people that they don't agree
with you find out why they don't and
then maybe we can just come together
because i feel like this is
i don't i don't like what i'm seeing out
there in these streets man i just don't
i don't like what i'm seeing on
instagram i don't like the politics
politics politicization of it i just
don't like it i don't i think they're
talking about the wrong issues you know
and we need to start talking about
you know let's talk about the right
issues you know what i'm saying people i
think i think you guys know what i'm
saying and i appreciate you guys
uh being here
so this was uh you know live riffing
with griffin
oh man you know what i forgot to do you
know what i gotta do it now i'm gonna do
it now because
i was i was so into it i forgot to do
my other ad which is supposed to be a
mid-roll but whatever let's just we'll
do it now with the music in the
background uh i'm gonna say a shout out
again to
doordash
you know i want to thank doordash for
being a sponsor of the show
uh you know doordash is great
[Music]
i use it
uh you know you know it's like you
backed up on meetings you try to run
errands you need food you want to get
you know you want to get food from your
favorite restaurant you want to get it
quick you know you use something like
doordash
you know it's it's it's so easy to use
and they got all your favorite
restaurants in your area that you want
to support and that's what we need to do
uh you know like i say and then you
don't even have to have you don't even
have to have clothes on they can deliver
the food right there at your door and
then you just when they're gone you open
it up i scream out thank you and then i
pick the the food up so it's great
um
look if you want to get what you want to
eat right now right to your door with
doordash along with the restaurants you
love you can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash
get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour you craving late
night ice cream donuts i love getting
donuts late
uh me and rachel always order we use
doordash and we get some donuts with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and cheesecake factory
for a little bit of time our listeners
get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
griffin that's 25 off 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code griffin don't
forget that's code griffin for 25 off
your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
[Music]
all right
i did my uh contractual obligations
i should have done it way sooner but
listen guys thanks for being here make
sure you check me out on twitch which
once i get all this straightened out i
gotta get the audio and stuff on
but make sure you check me out on twitch
i do that every single day on eric
griffin gaming i also have videos on air
griffin gaming on youtube i'll put a lot
of my victories on there so make sure
you guys check that out and i appreciate
you guys being here remember try to like
just try to have some nuanced
discussions
about this and don't get so emotional
and maybe we can change the world
together all right but anyways thanks
guys and i will see you
next week
[Music]
oh
[Music]